the blade of talin is a robust looking
ornamental sword that looks like a cross
between a Japanese Katana and a saber
this weapon is something of a history in
the Star Wars Universe mother talzin is
an important antagonistic figure in the
Clone Wars one who proves to be a
physical force to be reckoned with when
she takes on Jedi Master Mace Windu for
this purpose she conjures talin sword an
eerie looking blade that radiates green
magical iore and proves to be on par
with Windu's iconic purple lightsaber
it's a neat trick really the fact that
mother talzin can kn instantly summon a
sword that's able to match a lightsaber
means that she doesn't need to carry a
weapon instead she can simply create one
when necessary what's more night sisters
can use their magical ior to create all
sorts of solid objects which means that
the blade of talzin in a sooka May refer
to talin's technique of summoning a
sword instead of the object itself hence
it's slightly different appearance a
magic blade doesn't need to be carried
around and there's no technology to
maintain which makes it far more useful
than a lightsaber